I don't know I've got so many stories I
guess of emails because I guess it's my
fault because I kind of encouraged it a
little bit yeah yeah I've made multiple
videos where I've got content from my
email sometimes it's good but then also
I think now since I've joined an agency
I feel bad for the agency where they
sometimes I get said luckily I normally
like delete the ones that I know I like
like just trolling the four by agency
you can see it because I don't want some
Japanese worker opening my email and it
being like hey I think your dummy thick
and I'm 13
[Laughter]
that's like you get stuff where they'll
say like they they want to date you and
I'll put that 13 and like that it's just
like is this Chris Hansen is Chris
Hansen emailing yeah I think I've spoke
about this in a video once but there was
a someone who emailed me and I still
remember this cuz like I hadn't interact
I replied to it and it was this
interaction where they sent me a script
of phone sex that we were gonna have so
it was like it was like what I actually
still have the script I'm not gonna read
it out cuz there's more to the story
that there's the reason why I decided to
not make it into a video yeah but it was
like a script and it really it was first
it was one script was me and her and
there was also a music setlist that
she'd chosen so there was when the music
was it was like pour some like sugar on
me oh my you know like the cheesiest
song and so I thought in my head cuz
back there I read all of them in depth
and I thought wow this is a video idea
if I can like is going right and there's
also another script whereas me having
gay sex with the sebastian michaelis of
course of course
i mean that would be expected funny
that's like not the weirdest story I'm
surprised you didn't make a video Wow
okay so here's why and I feel bad I hope
this person isn't watching
so I interacted with them a bit and they
were like obviously I knew there could
be strange right because I'm sent an
email like that yeah and I start
interacting with them more and more and
then they started sending me way too
much information about themselves
there's also another guy who sent me is
birth certificate by the way that's a
whole nother what oh don't do that
turn that stage don't do that
I didn't ask for his opening email was
his my birth certificate driving license
address and I was like what I I also
mentioned this I don't know which video
I said I just mentioned all this but
yeah so I replied to this person I kept
replying with them because they kept
replying with really funny stuff right
yeah I was like oh my god I can get an
amazing video out of this yeah and then
with the one thing they said which made
me think okay now I just have to like
completely scrap all this is that they
said like oh here are my hobbies hobbies
blah blah blah by the way I'm in the
Special Olympics team for the USA but I
was like like why you shouldn't be
sending me this and then I explained to
them you know I was like hey maybe you
shouldn't send this email to me and yeah
I don't think this is like ya know
appropriate way and I'm really sorry for
like messing with your time and stop it
I just it was a whole thing where I was
like oh my god I'm an [ __ ] and Jesus
Christ like yeah but yeah there's so
many emails I've gotten well I mean I
made a whole video where I went on a
date with someone else yes a date yeah
from an email you were like Kaunas gonna
get canceled I remember you pitching
that video idea to me and I'm just like
I don't know that's the best idea but I
mean it turned out good video yeah I
pitched it to like ten ten of our
friends and everyone's like whoa whoa
whoa no don't do that don't do that I
love hockey my girlfriend was like
genuinely worried for you is like I
really don't think I was going to watch
the video they felt more concerned for
the girl because we turned up with light
me evan mood and another guy like one
girl alone right so thank you no but it
was like I am a wholesome in the end as
well home she's very nice about it yeah
yeah she's like the video sounds good
she just walked it to our casting couch